in january we did a segment about
a focus group that pollster and
researcher frank luntz did
with trumpists about their media
consumption
and how they end up believing things
about the election and what we found out
was not
particularly surprising a lot of fox
news a lot of news max a lot of oan it
was very eye-opening
frank luntz did another great focus
group a few days ago with
anti-vaccine trumpists these are
trumpists
who are hesitant to get the coronavirus
vaccine and we're going to look at some
clips here but the big takeaway
is that our suspicions about
anti-vaccine republicans and trumpists
appear to basically be correct which is
that a full year
of disinformation from trump downplaying
the pandemic
downplaying its severity that's a big
part of why
trumpists and republicans now in great
proportion
do not plan to get the coronavirus
vaccine so let's get right into it with
the first clip
then we'll talk about it when i say
covet 19
vaccination vaccine adam what do you
think of first
um a miracle albeit suspicious
lauren i'm sure too many questions
patrick rush
god from california experimental
aaron impressive but hesitant
marie gary not knowing the long-term
side effects
chad long-term side effects
unknown matthew experimental
and unknown how will effect long term
david from texas a
side effects diane from ohio
unproven lisa uh efficacy unknown
so these responses about the vaccine
range from the suspicious to the
completely debunked talking points
for example unproven and efficacy
unknown for example
it's quite the opposite the phase three
trials of these vaccines
approve that these are some of the first
most effective vaccines ever developed
by humans or by anybody
i don't know how many vaccines have been
developed by animals but these are some
of the most successful vaccines and
effective ones ever developed
huge efficacy at preventing symptomatic
illness period
and almost perfect at preventing serious
illness
we know that that's not an unknown
quantity they just don't know
rushed we've gone over this many times
the mrna platform
under development for decades
specifically
so that when you have a need for a
specific vaccine it's a faster process
it wasn't rushed
this is how long it takes to develop
mrna vaccines
possible long-term side effects you can
always say that
about any vaccine at any time the polio
vaccine was developed in 1955 that's 66
years ago
one could say how do we know side
effects don't start at the 67
year mark what we know about vaccines
and how they work this idea of
some future effect
is not a concern based on all of the
best medical science
so then they get into where do these
ideas come from
it's remarkable but it's also pretty
predictable
oh frank can i just say that it's all
very logical like i looked at this
logically there's no you know craziness
of because i think one way politically
that i can't look at logic and reason
and i think what you said very kind of
cavalierly about
so what that the pharmaceuticals let the
results out five days after the election
and to me that's a big so what it just
it makes you doubt a little bit of the
motives and the politicization of
science
so if you really want us to trust the
science i think politics has to be taken
out of it
and also if we could be if we could be
told that by being vaccinated things
would get back to normal again
and they don't even you know when that
happened and that happened
but that's not happening no things don't
wear masks
yep right still mask don't get together
with family
oh you could have a small gathering by
fourth of july
maybe maybe if we behave yes
people and a few hot dogs i mean that's
to me if everyone's getting vaccinated
we gotta move on and what you just saw
was what happens when politics gets put
in the middle of this
it's just gotta come out somehow i i
think that that is gonna be key to all
of this
that and ask yourself ask yourself who
put the politics there
which side had a benefit to having
politics introduced to this
and now they just keep it going it's not
going to be taken out now that last
comment
is interesting who had an interest in
injecting politics into this one of the
focus group participants said the
injection
of politics for personal benefit
on this pandemic in the united states
was trump and republicans
democrats had no interest in this case
in injecting politics democrats just
wanted to say let's do what the doctors
say
let's do what the public health experts
say trump calculated
if i downplay this if i disagree
with the public health experts it'll go
away and that's best for
me it's better for me politically not to
take this seriously at least publicly
and if it hadn't been that serious
donald trump
would have been easily re-elected i've
said that before if trump handled the
virus well he also would have been
re-elected
but the global handling of the virus
actually tells us that the best
political strategy
is the same as the best medical strategy
you step aside
and you listen to doctors new zealand
did it
australia did it taiwan did it rwanda
did it
there's other countries as well the
leaders where i mean okay
paul kagame in rwanda didn't need to do
well that's a different situation but
you look at new zealand and other other
places
when they did well with the virus they
did well politically and the best way to
deal
well uh with the virus was just to do
what the doctors said
but these folks believe that it's
democrats who injected politics
trump made a political call not a
medical call to
say 15 cases will soon be zero he
privately knew how much more serious it
was but he continued to downplay it
publicly
it was trump who initially injected
politics
let's continue it's not right nope the
fear-mongering
started at the beginning and it's never
ended right
and if there was a fact a point that i
want to see i want to see the data point
that says
when we reach herd immunity and what
percentage is there a percentage of the
population that could be vaccinated and
then we're herd immunity
because i have one minute the minute
they tell you that the goal pulse will
move again right because it was
how many days until we're done and we
can take off our masks in three weeks
until
if we all do this and it'll be over and
we're tired of that
they set it up and then it moves and so
how do you trust that if we all get to
vaccination level
we're going to be done with this and
don't forget the who changed the
definition of herd immunity
from natural to vaccinated
so talk about politicizing science
fear-mongering nearly 600 000 dead
officially probably 750 000 dead if you
include unreported or unofficial covet
deaths
what's funny about saying we don't trust
anything
now because we were told this would be
over in three weeks
those were the political statements
trump made in 2020 think about the the
lack of logic there
they don't trust biden now they don't
trust the vaccine now they don't trust
the government now
because trump said it'll be over by
easter of 2020
when obviously it wasn't going to be
over by easter of 2020.
they don't seem to realize that their
current mistrust of biden
who is being honest now about here's
what's going well but it could get worse
and i'll
if this isn't going so well i'm going to
tell you
that distrust of biden is based on
things
trump told them that were wrong now this
next clip is very interesting
i've guessed that even anti-vaccine
trumpists
once they see there are going to be
businesses that say we will require a
vaccine
maybe to fly with us maybe to go to a
concert that we organize whatever
that's going to get more people wanting
the vaccine
a bunch of the trumpists in the focus
group do say
travel requirements for example would
push me to get a vaccine not all of them
but some take a look
i'm not going to let you board a plane
without having a passport a digital
passport
that says that you got the covert 19
vaccine
if that were the case how many of you in
this
on this group how many of you would get
the vaccine
if you knew that you could not get on a
plane
okay so debbie would i i would delay it
as long as possible
i wouldn't i wouldn't rush to do it i
would just i would change my travel
plans yeah okay lauren you would do it
i love to travel i've been sitting you
know we haven't traveled
um i'm used to going away three four
times a year so if i
if this is the only way i could go away
i i i'm gonna have to take the
hands jen you would get jen from
iowa you get the vaccine if it meant
that you could travel by flight
i think eventually i would cave and i
would get the vaccine
even though like my husband and i both
survived covet last month
um he almost died but i still think that
at some point
i might be forced to do it and it would
i would rather it be my choice
than it be forced upon me by other
entities debbie if it meant you not
being able to fly or you being able to
fly you would get the vaccine
i would get the vaccine i absolutely we
love to travel
and we love to take cruises and so i
would i would
i would get it to travel so as you can
see some of them say
no no even to travel i'm not getting a
vaccine
but some of them say no i really like to
travel i'd probably get vaccinated if i
needed to
a a reluctant vaccinated person is still
vaccinated and that's
that that that's still i think the the
way the focus
should remain one other moment that's
interesting frank luntz brought in dr
tom frieden who's a former cdc director
and tom frieden gave the focus group
participants five
facts about vaccines it actually changed
a lot of minds
dr freedon i'm going to go to you now
because
doug says he wants facts let's go give
him four
facts and let's see if you can move them
right now one
if you get infected with the virus it
will go all over your body
and stay there for at least a week and
be much more likely to cause you
long-term problems than the vaccine two
if you get the vaccine it will prime
your immune system
but then the vaccine is gone it will not
be with you anymore
three more than 95 percent of the
doctors
who have been offered this vaccine have
gotten it as soon as they can
four the more we vaccinate
the faster we can get back
to growing our economy and getting jobs
and five if people get vaccinated
we're going to save at least a hundred
thousand lives
of americans who would otherwise be
killed by coving okay
i want to show of hands how many of you
would say that those five facts
are impactful to you raise your hands if
they're impactful
yeah wow wow that's a lot of you so most
people raised their hands there so the
upside is
not all is lost vaccination is
continuing to accelerate
we are now officially averaging 2.5
million doses per day
hopefully going to three we'll have a
full report on that tomorrow
but enough of these folks are
suffering the effects of such aggressive
disinformation
and confusion and partisanship
that mathematically were probably still
up against a pretty difficult
situation in terms of getting to herd
immunity on a national level
in areas with less vaccine hesitancy
it does seem like herd immunity is going
to be achievable
but we're going to have to hope that
travel restrictions or whatever
do push more of these folks to
ultimately get the vaccine
we'll have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram find us there
at david pakman show you may not have
known this but when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i
asked them to be a sponsor because they
are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are
which does not look good but what makes
teddy stratford shirts unique is this
patented zipper that's hidden underneath
the buttons which actually prevents the
chest from looking weird and stretched
out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt
in a specific way that makes your upper
body look a lot better it's just a much
nicer and more stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100 percent
egyptian cotton and flat-felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout